Okay.
Obviously a France in the 1920s and thirties has to be seen in terms of,
uh,
the international situation,
in Europe.
Uh,
and particularly the rise of fascism.
I mean,
it's easy to describe the 1920s in 1930s as the Europe of extremes.
And it's certainly,
that is certainly the case.
Uh,
and with,
with,
uh,
the Soviet Union,
but above all with the rise of,
of,
uh,
the,
the extreme right in,
in Europe by 1939 only I in central and eastern Europe,
uh,
only Czechoslovakia,
which would soon be munched by,
uh,
by Germany.
I had not only,
uh,
Czechoslovakia remained a parliamentary regime.
Uh,
and when you think of fascism,
you obviously think of Mussolini and taking a national socialism in Germany.
But one must also remember that,
that,
that all of the other states,
uh,
in central and eastern Europe became authoritarian states and parliamentary
regime has disappeared one after another.
And then of course,
uh,
I mentioned this in a while,
but the,
the,
the Spanish civil war brought Franco,
uh,
to power and we could debate long into the night with her.
Franco was a,
it was a fascist or just an authoritarian,
a right wing.
I'm a murderer.
Uh,
but,
um,
I that it was,
it's,
but it was part of the general scheme of things.
And even in countries in which,
uh,
democracy survives,
such as Belgium,
the Netherlands,
France,
which we're going to talk about obviously,
uh,
and Great Britain.
There were active fascist movements as though that,
that in,
in Britain led by Oswald Mosley was,
uh,
was a,
a quite small,
um,
so what I want to do today is discuss the rise of the right,
uh,
in France,
and then talk about the Popular Front,
uh,
which some people still view today.
It's a real magic moment in,
in,
in French history,
uh,
and,
the efforts of Leon Blum,
uh,
to create a new political world.
And finally,
uh,
it's,
um,
uh,
it's failure.
And so for the political details of the,
of the national block that,
that,
uh,
came to power immediately after the war,
um,
and the cartel,
they gauche,
um,
the cartel of the left,
uh,
which won the election in 1924.
I will lead leave that,
uh,
to,
your reading.
But one must remember that,
that in all of these countries and in France,
um,
uh,
among them,
the 1920 seemed to be,
uh,
the,
the temptation of the far right was,
was certainly there.
Mussolini was on the cover of Time magazine eight different times in this
country.
He became known as the man who got the Italian railroads to run on time.
Uh,
even if they only ran in time to the ski resorts that American Journalists,
uh,
to which American journalist tended to go.
Um,
Hitler doesn't come to power until January,
1933.
Uh,
and of course,
Hitler was the most successful of a whole bunch of,
of,
of right wing,
uh,
leaders in,
in,
in Germany,
all a determined to overthrow the Weimar Republic.
Uh,
so,
uh,
too many people attempted,
for example,
by corporate TISM,
the idea that somehow you could eliminate social strife by organizing industries
in a vertical way.
Uh,
mousseline he talked a good game about that and they actually made some efforts.
there was this,
this flirtation,
this temptation with,
uh,
the extreme right in the case of France.
Uh,
uh,
what,
what happens in,
in the 1920s and 1930s,
in particularly,
you know,
culminating in this day that I'll talk about February 6th,
1934,
uh,
you can see the origins of that before World War One in boot on Jay and in the,
the,
in the case of the Auntie,
a debate through sal.
Um,
so fascism is a European phenomenon and it became a French phenomenon.
Uh,
uh,
as well.
Uh,
the kind of official spokesman,
uh,
represented sort of the Canon of,
of,
of fascist,
uh,
slot was Lou de la Rochelle is every extremely good biography of him.
Uh,
uh,
several,
of him,
uh,
he was a novelist.
He's worked with obsessed whose life was obsessed with suicide.
And he became,
uh,
the first of a spiritual leader of French,
a fascist.
Uh,
he wrote an audit matter biographical novel called the zeal,
uh,
which he praised fascism is as being capable of affecting a spiritual revival of
what he considered to be a medieval Christianity.
And this would be a theme that would be very important under Vishi,
uh,
in the collaboration this year,
years of World War II,
uh,
as well.
Uh,
Sean from Oha,
whom we've read about,
uh,
who was the founder of actual phone says and who was a monarchist,
he also gets into the act any,
any urges France to,
to,
to expand to what he considered.
It's truly natural,
uh,
frontiers that is including the Left Bank of,
of the Rhine River.
Uh,
oxymorphone says,
uh,
is,
not really a mass movement the way that some of the other ones would be.
The quad differ though there were,
there were plebeian members of,
of optional phone says,
um,
it was more tied to a monarch ism than it was to the quest for the kind of
Mussolini or Hitler kind of dictator.
Uh,
but nonetheless it had considerable influence.
Um,
and in,
in France,
uh,
the,
the extreme right.
Uh,
and Catholicism work closely linked though obviously all practicing Catholics
were not,
uh,
extreme,
members of extreme right wing of movement,
but,
but a morass of sort of view with it,
a monarchy would restore that kind of Christian,
medieval virtue that that was largely imaginary.
Uh,
uh,
and that all this would come,
um,
uh,
come to pass,
hopefully in his,
in his lifetime.
Um,
and so they begin to create a unit.
I mean,
that's exactly what happens,
you know,
with,
with the Nazis and,
and,
and with the squads,
many of,
of,
of Mussolini,
uh,
in the early 1920s that bring him to power in 1922.
And so the soldiers as in the case of the German fry core,
the free core continue basically just to march.
And so the actual phone says,
takes the kind of tactics,
uh,
that were associated with,
or in the early stages with the blue launch j movement and argument I made
earlier,
uh,
and carry them now,
into the streets.
Um,
and,
uh,
with the,
the growth of,
of trade union members and France and other countries with the sort of flocking
of people too,
didn't say Jta,
the confederate Osteo in general due to why the General Federation of Labor.
Uh,
you had the,
uh,
the growth of these right wing,
groups,
uh,
who asked the German German German counterparts wanted to,
wanted to end parliamentary rural in France.
This,
by the way,
that actual phone says so over the top that it even scares the pope.
And Auction on frost says is condemned by the pope,
uh,
in,
19,
uh,
26 and indeed lots of members of oxygen from says who were faithful Catholics
leave the movement,
uh,
fearing that they're going to be,
excommunicated and a number of other groups,
uh,
us who are even more radical,
a startup.
Uh,
there's one group called [inaudible],
so,
uh,
the FAI,
s c e,
a u,
uh,
which had begun in 1919.
Uh,
but,
uh,
increase its membership and believes in violence,
struggle of this kind of action,
this kind of will to power that characterized national socialism as well.
Another of the quad differ,
the cross of fire attracted war veterans.
Uh,
not all of the war veterans,
uh,
ended up,
supporting the radicals are the socialists or the Communist.
Uh,
a good number of them go into right wing groups.
and this is certainly the case with the quad differ.
Uh,
it was founded in 1928 as a non political organization and its membership swells
to about 60,000 members.
Now,
there has to be money behind these movements as well as,
as well as ideology.
And it's kind of interesting that some of those are big money people are behind.
These movements were in luxury,
uh,
in luxury production.
Uh,
Coty for example,
the perfume maker,
uh,
was a big donor and believer in these far right wing clauses and,
and,
uh,
antisemitic causes.
Uh,
so was Tottan Jay Tats,
Nj,
the,
uh,
the champagne producer,
obviously another luxury good.
I once to took a bunch of Yale Alumni,
uh,
we went to APL may and to,
to grasp because they wanted to taste champagne was one of these field trips and
they were very nice group.
And,
uh,
we were,
being taken around the cove of,
of Tangy and I couldn't stand it.
They were telling us about what a great patriot heath on Jay was and all this
business and his portrait up there.
And I said,
well,
what happened?
What,
what happened during the 1930s.
I couldn't contain myself anymore.
What happened in the 1930s and World War Two?
And the woman looks terribly embarrassed and passed on to see if we would like
to taste yet another glass of champagne.
And the answer was a resounding yes.
Uh,
but,
um,
so the money,
a lot of the money came from,
from,
uh,
from folks like that.
And then because the newspapers,
I as in the case of Germany and most places were controlled by the right,
uh,
they have,
lots of,
of,
of ability to reach a large public [inaudible] himself,
or the name the spelling is ta I,
he founds the Patriotic Youth Movement in 1924,
which has that by the end of the decade,
100,000 members.
So these are our,
these are not small groups.
Now you have to the attraction of particularly middle class people to the far
right.
I is characteristic of Germany and Italy as well.
And this too has to be seen in the context of the hard times of the 1920s in the
1930s that Europe is basically in depression during the whole time except for
1924 to the big crash in 1929.
Uh,
Eastern Europe is in depression,
agricultural depression,
very severe agricultural depression during the entire time.
And so with,
with the kind of rampant inflation in France,
you didn't have anything similar to,
I mean not nothing,
uh,
comparable to what happens in Germany.
Everybody seen pictures of people pushing shopping carts down the street full of
millions and millions and millions of,
of uh,
deutschmarks a attempting to buy one single turnip.
Uh,
but the people who get burned and inflation are our,
particularly our middle class people who are on pensions and who have saved
their whole lives for retirement and with inflation,
their savings are wiped out in one single moment.
In the case of Germany is quite clear because in the early 90 [inaudible] be
hyperinflation of 22 and 23,
you had these German family wears white families who had to sell silver,
that had been in their families for generation or who had to sell antique arm
arm,
why that had been in their families for generation in order to have enough to
eat and they hate,
and they're going to blame somebody for this and who they're going to blame or
the Weimar republic.
And in the case of France,
they're going to blame the very existence of the republic.
And this lapse is in,
does elides into moves into various components of Fascist ideology,
uh,
that were shared by all of these movements everywhere,
is that they're rarely anti-socialist.
Anticommunist Hitler began by hitting before he hated Jews.
He hated Social Democrats.
Uh,
uh,
their auntie a Bolshevik,
their aunt and Auntie.
I'm a socialist or frightened by the,
the,
the revolution in Russia.
They're frightened by the fact that these communist parties are doing very well
in the states.
Uh,
they're also virulently anti Semitic,
and they're as arguing awhile xenophobic.
And they,
they,
uh,
run those two together because there's a large percentage of the people who come
into France,
particularly into Paris and the before World War One or Jews,
uh,
from eastern Europe and from Russia.
Uh,
and,
um,
in 1930s,
of course,
during the Spanish civil war,
you have a huge immigration of,
of,
of Spanish refugees fleeing a Franco's death squads,
uh,
and the civil war.
And so they share,
uh,
those characteristics as well.
Moreover,
the French right,
you know,
I've already been clear.
They hate parliamentary regime.
Uh,
the Europe of the 1920s and the 30s was the Europe of dictators and they wanted
one.
Uh,
and if,
if,
uh,
Sean Maha and the other action on phone says people wanted a king,
there,
there weren't very many likely candidates.
There wasn't,
you know,
it wasn't that there were a pretenders and both lines,
but there wasn't,
it wasn't going to just happen through some act of God.
Uh,
and they too could be,
uh,
could come to believe that dictatorship was,
was the only way of,
um,
you know,
of,
of solving the social.
And economic problems.
And they're all virulently nationalists.
I mean that,
that the,
the,
you know,
when you're talking about the annexation of the left bank of the Rhine,
or when Hitler's talking about elbows room,
a layman's with home elbow room expansion room for the German population,
uh,
it is,
is part of this theme of aggressive nationalism.
Uh,
and uh,
that also ties into the kind of xenophobia that is behind this entire,
uh,
movement.
And so xenophobia emerges as a key characteristic of the far right,
uh,
in France as well.
Now,
because the French population had stopped growing,
uh,
constant seem,
it only grows between 72 by 72,000,
between 1931 in 1936.
And as I said before,
two thirds of the did it pop them all in France had a smaller population in 1939
than they did in 18.
Uh,
uh,
51,
France has relatively few people under the age,
um,
uh,
under 20 years of age,
only about 31%,
which is extremely low percentage for,
uh,
compared to,
countries that have a really high rate of population growth.
Uh,
and relatively more,
uh,
people,
who were elderly and beginning in 1935 more people die each year in France and
not just in big cities than are born there.
So who makes up the difference?
Well,
uh,
Italians 720,000,
in France in 1936 poles,
425 styles and Spaniards,
255 styles.
And,
and there'll be lots more by 1939 for obvious regions and Belgium.
Belgium is 195,000.
Uh,
but also Jews,
the Jewish population of France,
uh,
it's about 320,000.
Uh,
and half of them had come to France since 1918.
So this immigration of very poor Jews from Poland and from Eastern Europe,
uh,
continues.
And so 7.5% of the French population and late thirties consists of immigrants.
It was the highest popular percentage of any country in Europe.
Um,
now if you want to also argue why,
with the exception of,
of Oswald Mosley striding around Hyde Park in his,
in his,
uh,
um,
you know,
in his black,
uh,
military like uniform,
Britain doesn't have much appeal to the far right.
And one of the reasons was is that immigration,
uh,
which is always,
this is this sort of lightening rod for,
uh,
for,
for a xenophobia was a,
uh,
was relatively small in a London company in England compared to these other
people,
places despite the fact that it was only in London and not in Paris,
where as early as the 18th century,
and even before that,
you would run into people of color because of the,
uh,
of the British empire.
So xenophobia is seized upon by these parties as an issue to rally support,
uh,
in elections,
but also on the streets.
Uh,
and if you think that's not the case,
now look at the success of the National Front,
uh,
in the 1980s in 1990s in France.
Uh,
and the kind of violent discourse of the far right in France,
uh,
today,
something,
uh,
to which we will come back to now.
Also,
let me just say,
let me just add that it's not that the parties of the left two are not exempt
from,
from xenophobia.
Uh,
and,
uh,
but,
but not to that anywhere to the same,
the same,
um,
uh,
extent that,
that,
uh,
the,
the parties of the,
of the far right built their base upon upon xenophobia.
I have a former dissertation student who now teaches at Penn state,
who was a wonderful thesis on,
uh,
so the police,
the way they tracked,
uh,
immigrants who were supporters of the Communist Party in Paris in the,
in the 1930s,
uh,
particularly people from West Africa,
and from,
uh,
from,
from Guadalupe.
And,
and so the flirtation of,
of,
of some,
uh,
immigrants to Paris,
particularly people of color with,
with the,
the far left,
intensifies the hatred of the part by the parties of the far right of,
of,
of immigrants.
And their idea of what they called true France.
That is this true Catholic,
medieval,
uh,
of France rooted in the soil,
did not include,
uh,
in their,
fantasies of aggressive nationalism,
did not include,
uh,
immigrants.
Uh,
this is,
you know,
it's,
it's an obvious theme from the 1920s and in 1930s,
though,
Hitler with his own,
you know,
his own,
not uniquely,
but,
but over the top pernicious biological,
uh,
view of race,
was the one who took it to its extreme saying that he,
the fuel her,
the,
the leader,
uh,
or the equivalent of the Duci,
that's what they called them in,
uh,
in,
in Italy or the cardio in,
in Spain.
He would have the right to say who lives and who dies,
who is part of the German Volk,
the German people and who is not.
And of course,
Hitler runs into some difficulty,
very minor with German population because he begins to,
uh,
to,
use euthanasia as a tool of the state and to kill people who are handicapped or
mentally retarded,
uh,
as well as Jews and Gypsies and,
and,
and uh,
and gays,
uh,
right along the way.
And then a lot of Germans say,
wait a minute,
but,
but this,
this,
uh,
these poor people who are mentally retarded,
that you're,
that you're killing or you're ready letting your doctor's experiment on their
real Germans,
do what you want with the others,
uh,
do with what you want with,
with the,
the immigrant Jews or,
or the Jews who were born there and assimilated,
but leave the real Germans alone.
So,
I mean,
this is an awful kind of discourse even to consider,
but it,
it,
um,
uh,
it,
it is really part of,
uh,
of this great movement,
this groundswell in France as well in other countries against a parliamentary
rule.
Now I'm,
this culminates isn't making a very long story short,
but this culminates,
of course,
it's February 6th,
1934.
And,
uh,
um,
the phone popular,
the Popular Front,
um,
uh,
a political scandal gives the extreme right an opportunity for action.
Um,
now this is a country that had all these political scandals before that they had
survived,
uh,
and not just the Dreyfus affair,
but the view.
So unfair and,
and,
and all of this business that we talked about,
uh,
and the Panama Canal,
a scandal that we talked about before that discredited the republic.
Um,
and so now the republic accuses of not only being soft,
not virile,
uh,
full of sort of coralling of rotating ministries,
a weak system without a strong executive authority.
But again,
of being,
uh,
being corrupt.
And drew allow,
Rochelle boasted,
he says,
the France of,
of,
of camping out that is getting up in the morning and plunging into frozen ponds
and the will Vannia and being a boy scout and all of this stuff,
I will conquer the France of the APP at home.
That is the,
the,
the drink after drink before meals.
And the rightest shouted down with the France of the APERITIF.
Uh,
what an idea down with the France of the before meal drink.
And it's a matter of fact,
during a 1934 during the heyday,
there were signs posted in cafes,
uh,
around the sham did deputy around the palisade were born.
They said,
no,
served here.
We just want,
we want people who are against the Republican come in and drink here.
We don't want people who,
who represent the republic.
And,
um,
uh,
the police,
make it very difficult to,
uh,
they looked the other way as he sort of right wing groups,
mobilize their forces in the streets.
I mean,
and again,
I said this before,
but it's true that the,
you look at the whole period,
1914 to 1944,
45 is a 30 years war because basically Europe is still at war I,
and it's a war waged on different levels and intellectual level,
a newspaper,
violent headlines Level and,
and battles in the street.
Uh,
and you know,
these people are playing for keeps.
Um,
a very shady character called Sanchez.
Dubiski played by John Paul had been that a Mondo in the film,
um,
was Ukrainian Jew who had come to France with his family as a small boy.
He made his living basically by cheating people.
He was a con guy.
Um,
his father committed suicide out of shame for the way that his son made his
income.
One of his cleverest projects,
but most deal sated was involving the sale of municipal bonds in that Bosc town
of [inaudible],
uh,
down,
near the Spanish boarder,
um,
in the Pyrenees Atlantic in the boss.
I'm a boss country in southwestern France.
Uh,
there was a dummy company that had been created to cover up the operation and,
and lots of reputable insurance companies had invested and lost a lot of money.
US Dubiski had a lot of money because of this and he loved the good life.
He loved fast cars.
He loved fancy women and he loved spending other people's money.
He loved great restaurants.
Uh,
having a 36 roses delivered to his,
his chosen lover of the evening,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But gradually it all collapses on his head.
And He,
in December,
1933,
he flees to the Alps near Chamonix and he rents the villa.
You didn't just flee to a small room,
uh,
in Lavonne Shay or someplace like that.
You have to have a villa and,
and,
and let people know that these are still living very well.
And revelations a pile up.
One after another,
a minister of the government had written enthusiastic letter recommending of the
bonds.
Uh,
but it's Dubiski was,
had been protected by an obliging state prosecutor who happened to be the
brother-in-law of the prime minister,
a forgettable character called [inaudible] tall.
And so actional front says his newspaper has a big headline on the 7th of
January,
1934 down with deceives or urging a large protest against the Chamber of
Deputies.
The police are on a [inaudible] trail.
They arrive in Chamonix,
they find out what man dressed,
carry lots of flowers and dressed in white has rented a villa up in the hills.
And they get,
as they're moving in to arrest him at this villa,
he blows his brains out and this bursts into a full fledge political crisis,
uh,
that,
came close to bring down the republic.
Now,
the police didn't bother to call a doctor until they were sure that Stravinsky
was dead.
And this raises all sorts of concern,
uh,
because of the obvious issue that he might reveal a highly placed people with
whom he was working.
He left a suicide note,
signed a to his son,
signed you're unhappy Daddy.
And it might've been forged.
There was something not quite right about the writing.
That's Dubiski was a Jew caused all of the,
and he might have been,
you know,
it's something else,
but he happened to be a Jew,
uh,
caused,
the right wing organizations,
uh,
to go wild.
And the demonstrations became nothing less than an attack on the Republican
demonstrations turned into riots,
uh,
particularly after another minister,
is implicated in the state scandal and short,
tall bags.
It on the 27th of January.
And there's another,
there's another coalition government,
yet another one that this has caused,
uh,
to come into existence.
Uh,
Shakespeare.
Shakespeare has a play Coriolanus,
uh,
a play that has strong authoritarian implications,
was wildly applauded that the comedy fall says,
and the young patriots vowed a sweep away.
The Socialist Party,
the Communist Party and dirty Jewish finance.
Uh,
the police,
the prefect of police is a guy called John [inaudible],
c h,
a.
P.
E.
He appeared quite unconcerned with the right wing riots in the streets,
but he ordered the bashing of any leftwing heads that could be seen,
uh,
when,
the new head of the government,
a Dell Ida,
whom you can read about called shop telling him of his dismissal.
The policemen refused to be sent to Morocco and promised that he would be in the
street,
uh,
suggesting to Dillard,
Yay.
Not a fear of unemployment,
that he was going to be in the street because he's unemployed.
But a promise to lead,
uh,
the overthrow of the republic.
And on February 4th,
1934,
every grit right wing group plans to meet in,
uh,
in,
um,
before the Chamber of Deputies.
They marched on the Sean sleazy or come from other direction.
My favorite group in this is one small group of people,
uh,
are marching down the street and down and they're all ready to go and join the
others.
They look at somebody who looks at his watch and said,
well,
it's seven 30.
[inaudible] and so they leave and they say it's time to eat.
And so they leave the demonstration to go eat and then they miss the whole thing
cause they're having some sort of lavish meal someplace.
I wouldn't have been any right wing demonstration,
but I would have left.
I could tell you to go eat,
uh,
as well.
And so that what happens is they go sailing,
they go charging across the,
the,
the San River.
Uh,
they're trying to liberally overthrow the republic.
their debates,
whether it was just a,
it was a real coup d'etat tamped and overthrow or whether this demonstrating,
uh,
the police,
badder than back.
I have an uncle who was a communist who,
uh,
was doing a psychoanalytic training in,
in Berlin in those days.
And,
and there was a very active communist and he claims to have been a counter
demonstration I and who have been grazed by a bullet because the communists were
there as a,
as a counter demonstration.
And I don't know,
his stories became a more and more,
uh,
lavish over the years.
But he was a wonderful man.
Um,
and he probably,
and he probably was there,
so,
um,
there were 14 demonstrators killed and several thousand injured.
So this is a very big,
uh,
event and several hundred policemen.
Also,
we're,
um,
we're hurt a Dell ida resigns on February 8th.
But the big significance of this event was it,
this is a real attempt to overthrow the republic.
And on February 12th,
the largest demonstrations in French history,
uh,
until 1968 occurred in every single prefecture and France outside of two or
three,
uh,
in defense of the republic and the Popular Front,
that alliance between the radicals whom you remember our socially moderate,
but very anticlerical,
but they have lost their rezone death a little bit.
The Socialists and the communists.
This alliance to save the Republic against fascism emerges out of this fat
Acompli of these popular demonstrations of people pouring in to,
uh,
into this treat.
Millions of French men and women and children March,
uh,
in France,
it's followed by a 24 hour strike.
Uh,
this Dubiski affair was kept alive by the discovery of the mangled body of the
public prosecutor of the Paris court,
which had been tied down on the railroad tracks.
Uh,
so that he was a clock by the five 12,
uh,
train between Paris and,
and does y'all,
uh,
and cut in half.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the republic seem to have a new lease on life,
but as one of his critics said,
it could also be called a new lease on death,
but something had been changed because the three major parties had been,
uh,
had been frightened.
Now in 1920,
you will know,
you will remember that at the Congress of tool,
uh,
the communist party,
a split away from the Socialist Party and the Communist Party retains some
elements of that old guest party that you remember.
Uh,
did I'll be discussing before world war one.
It was not discussing before we're all one,
but we discussed it before we got to World War One.
Uh,
in that it was a sort of a top down,
uh,
organization,
the democratic centralism decisions made at the top,
and then informing the party faithful of what they would be,
uh,
was an essential part of,
in 19 2122 and 23,
uh,
mostly 22,
23,
if I remember correctly,
the communists intellectuals were thrown out of the party.
Uh,
the Communist Party,
uh,
quite slavish Lee a bade every order that came from Moscow,
its leaders were a minors,
like to has a or industrial workers.
Uh,
but because they provided very good social services,
particularly in the red belt,
those suburbs around Paris,
uh,
had,
had the prestige that long predated,
uh,
the real role,
heroic role of communist resistance,
uh,
in World War Two.
Uh,
but they considered Leon Blum and the Socialist Party,
uh,
to be anathema.
For one thing bloom was,
was a,
was a bourgeois himself and the socialist party was willing to compromise with
other parties.
Was reformist a party in this tradition of John.
John Has Leon Blum,
who was born on the,
and a knee in Paris.
Uh,
there's still a plaque.
There was an intellectual,
uh,
he was a literary critic.
He was a writer.
He had written a pamphlet on,
called on marriage,
which is considered scandalous before war one in which he said it was okay not
to marry,
but simply,
you know,
be with somebody and all of that for a long period of time.
It was a recognition of the fact that in many places,
people weren't married,
uh,
simply lived together and in particularly in large cities and particularly in
Paris,
and is your ass was killed on the 31st of July,
1914 Leon Blum was the logical successor of Joe has,
he had an ability to bring people in a room and to get them unified and,
and,
and he,
uh,
and he becomes the dominant figure in the Socialist Party.
But Leon Blum,
there was something else about him that mattered as well,
uh,
in the Popular Front and the France before that is it.
Leon Blum was also Jewish.
And the one thing that you heard from 1934,
1935,
1936,
is well dressed,
uh,
students probably from the fuck a Da da Sausa,
in,
in Paris,
right wing students,
a shouting better Hitler than bloom.
And at one point,
Leon Blum was pulled out of his car and the root days they call near the
Sorbonne and,
and almost beaten to death by right wing thugs.
Leon Blum was Jewish now,
uh,
and he was an intellectual.
So it,
the communist party in a way was the case of the tail wagging the dog because it
was the communist militants that really demanded that some,
that there'd be a block against fascism,
but the communist party finds itself allied with,
uh,
the Socialist Party.
And these are not small numbers.
The number of people in the Communist Party,
there were by 1936,
they were 330,000 members of the Communist Party.
And again,
I mean,
there are particularly powerful in the red belt around Paris,
but,
but big influence and in places like the Rda and then,
yeah,
in,
in the board room.
And a essentially,
uh,
you know,
in the industrial regions of the north,
they do very,
very well,
uh,
places where the Geddes had done well,
in,
in the 19th century.
So they do really well among,
among industrial workers and above all among railroad workers.
And that's still the case today.
The shemy know the railroad engineers and the railroad workers still,
you know,
the company's Party's lost most influence,
but the influence of the party and the,
and the General Confederation of Labor is still seen whenever there's a big
train strike and France and you're stuck in a station for,
you know,
hours and hours because the train is,
it is not coming.
And so in the meantime,
government after government,
uh,
it follows,
um,
and so,
uh,
in June,
1934,
the communist party repudiates what they called class versus class strategy that
is making possible the alliance now with the Bourgeois,
a party that is the Socialist Party.
Lots of workers support the socialist parties.
But for the Communist Party,
uh,
the,
it was a socialist party was inevitably the boars wild party.
That was their discourse.
And the three parties meet and per po prepare a compromise program that
incorporated tax reform,
a shorter work week,
increased unemployment benefits,
international disarmament support for the League of nations and the dissolution
of the fascist leagues.
You can get this out of the book,
but basically that's it.
Um,
so,
uh,
on the 7th of March,
1936,
German armies moving into the Rhineland and now the threat to the republic
inside France scene's been marched by Hitler's a winning the big bluff,
uh,
against,
the League of nations and against the allied powers.
I,
after World War One,
and in fact,
killers general said,
you know,
[inaudible],
I wouldn't do this because our army is weak.
Now we're rebuilding.
They were already,
their pilots are being trained by Soviet pilots already a way before the rub,
a Molotov Ribbentrop Pat Ribbentrop Pact of 1939,
uh,
they said,
you know,
my fear that I wouldn't do this because even the Belgian army and the French
army,
you know,
it's hard to imagine the Belgian army very strong,
but,
but the German army member had been dismissed.
Demobilize essentially.
Uh,
and Hitler.
Hitler says we're going to do it anyway,
and he gets away with it.
So what this does is it leads to,
in the elections of May of 1936,
a victory of the Popular Front,
57% of the vote,
um,
with the Socialist Party.
Now the largest party in France,
and they have 386 of 608 seats in the Chamber of Deputies.
Now,
the Communists refused to participate in the cabinet because they don't want to
be associated with any failure,
but yet they're adding to this mix of three has made the victory,
uh,
possible.
And so Leon Blum becomes prime minister on the 3rd of June,
1936 with,
we know,
under threats all the time because of the fact he was Jew Jews.
Oh,
he was a Jew.
Um,
now what happens next is that the largest wave of strikes in France until that
year,
again,
1968 breaks out because workers encouraged by the,
the Popular Fronts preelection promises.
Now,
uh,
go on strike in June,
1936,
there 12,000 strikes involving 2 million workers,
more strikers than anytime.
And for the first time ever.
Now this happens also in Flint and Detroit at the same time,
workers occupied factories,
they occupied factors they put on guerrilla theater or they do performances in
which they play the,
you know,
some guy plays the bad guy,
the boss or the,
the Co,
the cultural mathical,
the,
the foreman,
uh,
or the Pinkerton,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So they're occupying these factories in places like knots and Boulogne belong
the bigger an olfactory outside of Paris.
Um,
and so it,
you know,
there are preexisting grievances,
a conditions of work.
Taylorism,
a worker remembered.
There are two factors in the slavery that we face.
Speed and orders.
One must must,
well,
putting myself in front of the machine,
kill one soul,
eight hours a day.
One's thoughts,
one's feelings,
everything.
Pete workers in France still refer to the factory is a bind ya a Banya is a
prison bag.
And He,
uh,
again,
the idea that you're,
you're a prisoner there while you're there and you're under the direct orders
of,
of the foreman or the boss,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And um,
what,
what is interesting is that the strikes take the labor federations and the
communist party by surprise,
the communist leaders say,
wait a minute,
what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Is the tail wagging the dog?
And they say,
memorably everything is not possible.
And the workers reply,
everything is possible and they don't want to lose the influence of the party.
And this isn't the first,
the last time this would happen because it happens in 1968 also the comments,
as I said,
what are you people striking?
We didn't give you orders to go on strike.
What do you think you're doing?
What they thought they were doing is representing their own interests.
Um,
and so humanity,
the Communist newspaper has a huge,
uh,
title groty.
Everything is not possible.
But,
uh,
now who should Leon Blum have called on the workers and the peasants to initiate
them a more radical form of,
of Popular Front.
Uh,
well,
you know,
probably not.
But what he does is he calls the government,
uh,
and the employers that they're all gonna get together and meet and they form,
they do what they're called the Martino agreements.
I'm sure I didn't write this on the board.
I should have mat I,
G,
N,
O,
n,
which are a great victory for the workers.
The employers accepted the unions as the representatives of their workers and
would negotiate with the unions and give them a raise of 12 to 15%.
They promised the 40 hour a week.
And we take that for granted.
And France is a big issue over the 35 hour week,
as I'm sure you know,
and they give paid vacations and the paid vacation of a month with many people
now in France can't afford to take,
comes out of the Popular Front.
They also opened up the Louvre free certain days of the week on Sunday,
the sort of a culture revolution as well.
And the,
and there you see all kinds.
There's me.
I wish we had three hours to talk about this,
but you probably don't,
but I do.
But,
uh,
that,
that they,
they,
they're these great postcards at pictures of people had never seen the ocean
that live 50 miles or 50 kilometers from the ocean.
People from Ras,
and they go to [inaudible],
which is near Dunkirk,
which of cold frozen beach.
And,
and they're so proud and they're there in their bathing suits,
free,
modest bathing suits,
and they have their pictures together with the sea behind them.
Something they'd never seen before.
And lots of her working class resorts,
uh,
developed during that time.
Not Everybody can afford to go to central pay or Dovii or,
or via heats,
uh,
or South [inaudible] or God forbid,
con and places like that.
Uh,
so the working class vacation begins then.
And that's a great moment.
That's a magic moment.
That's an,
that's an important moment.
And when we live in a country,
which nobody ever takes vacation,
people that are rich can't afford to take vacations,
you know,
they make all this money.
What are they going to spend it?
Well,
this get another 500 video games or something like that.
You know,
what are they going to do?
Uh,
uh,
and you know,
in France,
the right to a vacation,
even a few you can't afford to take.
Now.
People just take smaller vacations than they could before.
That's an important conquest and it came from the Popular Front and it's great,
great,
great sing.
Now the wealthy French families don't like this very much.
What happens if these people come to our resorts speaking like they do,
looking like they do,
they don't like it.
What kind of,
is this your new,
hey,
put beacon pope you that you know,
after all.
And so,
uh,
the,
the strikes,
uh,
the,
the strikes gradually end.
But why does the Popular Front fail in the long run?
In a way?
Everything wasn't possible.
It wasn't possible.
Um,
one of the reasons that fails is because of course the employers have no,
no,
uh,
idea of,
of,
of holding to what they had agreed to and they violate every conceivable
contract they can as quick as quickly as possible.
Um,
but the economic crisis,
uh,
you know,
if you're trying to make,
make France more productive and people put people back to work at the time,
the strategy of having people work less or for that matter going out on strike
economically didn't really work.
It does.
I mean,
the Francis of was a more agricultural country than say,
Germany or the United States or Britain.
And so the depression comes longer and it stays,
you know,
I mean,
it comes later in,
it stays longer than the u s doesn't get out of the depression.
And really,
uh,
until the armaments,
19,
um,
you know,
a,
a World War World War II.
Um,
and you know,
the export of currency,
what wealthy people do and France and other countries.
So they start taking money and,
uh,
cash gold,
silver out of the country.
They take them to Switzerland.
They still do that.
I mean,
and especially in the 1990s,
they were having to control the trains to Switzerland and Bruce l develop them
because people were taking money out of the country and all of that,
and not declaring,
declaring what they had his income.
I mean,
that,
that's the,
you know,
it just happens all the time.
Um,
so,
uh,
it blossomed,
does not allow,
loomed is not a,
I'll put controls on currency,
uh,
constraints on currency,
because of opposition from the British and the United States and other places.
And so at this point,
the Popular Front begins to unravel a ideologically the reform of Socialist
Party and the Communist,
uh,
remain a world of part lay on is not going to say occupy permanently.
The factories take over the means of production.
That's all there is to it.
No,
he wasn't going to do that.
Um,
in,
in March,
in 1937,
the police fire on workers demonstrating against the quad tougher,
uh,
in the Parisian suburb of Clichy and the Communist Party denounces the
government,
the French stock market goes into a,
a tumble various advisors,
uh,
um,
resign a reducing confidence in blems economic policy in Leon blooms economic,
uh,
policies.
And the government had to devalue the frank several times,
uh,
because of the flow of gold abroad and the French,
um,
uh,
financial,
community denounces,
uh,
Leon Leon Blum.
Um,
but there's another reason too,
uh,
that undercuts the Popular Front.
And this,
of course it's Spain,
uh,
because those people who lived in the late 1930s people who were intellectuals,
people who were students at Yale and Columbia and MIT,
Michigan and Tau and other places.
Uh,
the war in Spain was seen as a war of civilization.
at the time people realized that it was a dry run for a,
another big war that was going to come along that sometime fascism had to be
stopped.
Uh,
and,
uh,
Franco,
his military legions,
he was actually number three on the list,
but the first two were killed.
One in combat,
I guess in the,
in the,
the other one in a plane accident flying from Portugal into Spain.
Uh,
the revolution a counterrevolution the really starts in 1936 in Morocco and then
in Spain.
Uh,
and by 1939,
uh,
in a very bloody atrocity,
full war on both sides of the atrocities were overwhelmingly on the side of the
fascists.
Have no question about that.
Um,
the question was what was going to happen in Spain and some of the great
literature that came out of that period.
Obviously it's George Orwell's homage to Catalonia or Borkin Hour Brennan.
There's all sorts of great books on Spain from people who were there.
The international brigades were full of people from Yale and Columbia and Oxford
and Cambridge,
uh,
and the unions in Detroit going over to fight the good fight against fascism.
Uh,
but nobody gave arms to Spain.
Nobody gave arms to Spain except the Germans gave arms to,
uh,
the authoritarians of Franco.
The Italians tried out there,
their tanks there.
Uh,
the guarantee of the most famous painting of the period of,
of,
of Picasso French should visit guarantee has sometime came when,
uh,
they distract strafe and vomits civilian population.
It was German planes doing it.
Uh,
on behalf of Franco.
And Leon Blum goes to the plastic republic and they're thousands and thousands
of people and they're screaming arms for Spain,
arms for Spain,
arms for Spain.
And with tears pouring down his cheeks,
he said,
I can't,
I can't.
Well,
why couldn't he?
Because the British and the Americans didn't want him to do that.
They viewed,
uh,
the,
they,
they viewed this as being a internationalization of a war which had already
become internationalized.
And Spain did not get the weapons that needed to survive.
And Franco's regime last until 1975.
November,
1975 when he finally,
uh,
expired the war,
you know,
that was one of the warrant.
Spain was one of those moments.
You can look back,
and I already suggested this,
that maybe if they'd stopped Hitler,
you know,
when they invade,
invade the Rhineland,
maybe history would have been different.
Could have been.
You never know.
And maybe if they stopped Franco in,
in 19,
uh,
36 to 1939 and in doing so,
stop the Germans and Italians,
maybe history would have been different.
And all of these,
uh,
50,
who can count 50 million or 60 million or about people who died,
uh,
wouldn't have died.
Who knows?
It's looking back.
But as so far as of Popular Front,
it's survived.
But in name only until 1939,
the economic crisis,
uh,
the,
the strike movement and all of that,
which in a way was counterproductive.
And the war of Spain,
uh,
and the international situation,
came to,
uh,
represent,
to bring about the defeat of this government.
And Leon Blum is most of,
you know,
ends up in jail.
He's lucky.
A drink Vichy not to have been assassinated.
He survives or not to get murdered or executed.
Uh,
he survives the war,
uh,
and is active in politics again at the very beginning of what would become the
fourth republic.
But we live in a world in the stall Shah,
and the historical nostalgia too.
And people,
you know,
people of my generation,
I mean,
I wasn't born then,
I assure you that even near being born yet then,
uh,
but we,
you know,
we grew up listening to tales of Spain and arms for Spain.
And one,
you know,
if one lives in France,
uh,
lots of the things that they're,
they're good about France and,
and the sort of the protective state in giving people the right to decent
conditions,
uh,
the,
and decent,
decent healthcare museums that are actually open and paid vacations are
something that came out of that period.
And so one looks sort of backwards,
a certain bit of nostalgia.
So next Wednesday we will move on to the fall of France and to collaboration and
World War II.